Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see if Waymo’s AI
can recreate a virtual copy of San
Francisco from 2.8 million photos.
To be able to do that, they rely on a previous
AI-based technique that can take a collection
of photos like these, and magically, create a
video where we can fly through these photos.
This is what we call a NERF-based technique,
and these are truly amazing. Essentially,
photos go in, the AI fills in the gaps, and
reality comes out. And there are a lot of
gaps between these photos, all of which are
filled in with high-quality synthetic data.
So, as you see with these previous methods, great
leaps are being made, but one thing stayed more or
less the same: and that is, the scale of these
scenes is not that big. So, scientists at Waymo
had a crazy idea, and they said, rendering
just a tiny scene is not that useful. We have
millions of photos laying around, why not render
an entire city like this? So, can Waymo do that?
Well, maybe, but that would take Waymo'. I am
sorry. I am so sorry, I just couldn't resist.
Well, let’s see what they came up with. Look,
these self-driving cars are going around the city,
they take photos along their journey, and…well,
I have to say that I am a little skeptical here.
Have a look at what previous techniques could do
with this dataset. This is not really usable, so,
could Waymo pull this off? Well, hold on to
your papers, and let’s have a look together.
My goodness…this is their fully reconstructed
3D neighborhood from these
photos. Wow. That is superb.
And don’t forget, most of this
information is synthetic. That is,
filled in by the AI. Does this mean that? Yes!
Yes it does! It means three amazing things.
One, we can drive a different path that
has not been driven before by these cars,
and still see the city correctly.
Two, we can look at these
buildings from viewpoints
that we don’t have enough information about,
and the AI fills in the rest of the details.
So cool! But it doesn't end there, not even close.
Three, here comes my favorite. We can also engage
in what they call appearance modulation.
Yes, some of the driving took place at night,
some during the daytime, so we have information
about the change of the lighting conditions.
What does that mean? It means that we can
even fuse all this information together
and choose the time of day for our virtual
city. That is absolutely amazing. I love it.
Yes, of course, not even this technique
is perfect, the resolution and the details
should definitely be improved over time.
Plus, it does well with a stationary city,
but with dynamic moving objects, not so
much. But do not forget, the original,
first NERF paper was published just
two years ago, and it could do this.
And now, just a couple papers down the line, and
we have not only these tiny scenes, but entire
city blocks. So much improvement in just a couple
papers. How cool is that. Absolutely amazing.
And with this, we can drive and play
around in a beautiful virtual world
that is a copy of the real world around us. And
now, if we wish it to be a little different,
we can even have our freedom
in changing this world
according to our artistic vision. I would
love to see more work in this direction.
But wait, here comes the big question. What
is all this good for? Well, one of the answers
is sim2real. What is that? Sim2real means
training an AI in a simulated world, and
trying to teach it everything it needs to learn
there before deploying it into the real world.
Here is an amazing example, look, OpenAI
trained their robot hand in a simulation
to be able to rotate these Rubik cubes. And then,
deployed this software onto a real robot hand,
and, look! It can use this simulation knowledge,
and now it works in the real world too.
But sim2real has relevance to self-driving cars
too. Look. Tesla is already working on creating
virtual worlds, and training their cars there. One
of the advantages of that is that we can create
really unlikely and potentially unsafe scenarios,
but, in these virtual worlds, the self-driving AI
can train itself safely. And when they deploy
them into the real world, they will have all
this knowledge. It is fantastic to see Waymo also
moving in this direction. What a time to be alive!
So, what would you use this for? What do you
expect to happen a couple more papers down the
line? Please let me know in the comments
below. I’d love to hear your thoughts.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!